während unser lieblings youtuber von
hinten die haben uns hier heute
versammelt meine damen und herren denn
ich habe ein paket bekommen und zwar
dass hier und da ist eine menge menge
fun geschenke drin da ist meine adresse
die dürfte nicht sehen auf jeden fall
hat der fleißige zuschauer schon
mitbekommen dass ich mittlerweile ein
fan der post fach dings wie auch immer
das heißt habe auf jeden fall hat er
jetzt mein manager eine sachen hierzu
geschickt und da sind auf jeden fall
eine menge pakete drehen und ich hab mir
gedacht okay bekommen bevor dieses paket
zu vergammeln oder keine ahnung was ich
das einfach mal zusammen mit euch
auspacken werde ich habe jetzt gerade
alle sachen mal eben kurz hingelegt
wir sind eine menge menge von so ganz
normalen brief mit dabei wo wir heute
wahrscheinlich irgendwas geschrieben
haben ich weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt
wieder auspacken soll das event auch
private sachen sein könnten
deswegen will ich sagen dass ich die
briefe jetzt erstmalig zur seite aus
pappe auf packte vor allem schlägt die
da hin wenn paar sekunden später sind
die pakete wir haben jetzt hier so die
pakete erst mal rum liegen die ganzen
briefe liegen jetzt hier links das hier
ist das messer mit dem wir das auspacken
werden ich würde sagen das messer auch
eigentlichen namen messi leoni leoni
[Musik]
leoni ist jetzt schon mal auf video von
mir reagiert also da wir jetzt die
lionel messi am start haben würde ich
sagen dass wir jetzt mal mit dem ersten
paket hier anfangen das paket kommt von
der liebe nennen das paket unternehmen
lena dass er lena meyer landrut danke
die galina wie hast du das papier karton
muss man vor allem auch erstmals
stellten hier mega suite diese schenkt
mir jeder mensch am pult stinkt's gehört
das erste was mir die lena zugeschickt
hat ist ein
eine klobürste also danke ich und bürste
enjoy life in the secret life freunde
wenn ihr mir solche pakete schickt dann
hört doch bitte auch für diesen konfetti
also ich meine sieht schön aus so dass
alles immer zeit sei das war eine
klobürste drinnen dark auf jeden fall
darf er dann haben wir hier ein duschgel
von den em- oder heben die sowas ist und
dann noch so ein bisschen kleinen trams
also hier irgendwie ein schnuller warum
schickt ihm den schnuller danke
geyrhalter die lena hat wirklich mit
gedacht jetzt hab ich endlich mein bart
und brille sich gebildet aus lucka hier
sind zwei crazy girls und wir verfolgen
die ich schon seit jahren levy und lena
wir beide hoffen schon lange dass wir
endlich einen pauls fahrt macht und
siehe da endlich hast du einen
dankeschön auf jeden fall an euch linie
und lena ich werde mit dem brief nach
hinten durchlesen
ja das ist das gewand genau hier bin ich
hey lass doch mal allen like a wheel
toddlers man wirklich leichter also wenn
ich das öfter machen sondern vielleicht
findet ihr das ja auch nicht wenn ich
das auspacken paket im paket ein paar
sekunden später wieder alles vollmann
konzert also hier ist wieder mega viel
von so klein krams drin der hier die
ganze herumfliegt wieder durch mein
zimmer im das paket kommt von der teens
sind arbeit hat nur noch mehr konfetti
drin ich freue mich dass so etwas ist
mega gut weil ich wollte er heute noch
sagen
china hat ein bild gemalt und hat mir
einen brief geschrieben und das bild ist
das hier das heißt das würde ich sagen
hängt man direkt auf dessen
ich habe keinen kleber doppelt danke auf
jeden fall an tina für das paket nur
noch geringfügig konzert ihr um dieses
paket ist von amazon
also ich weiß nicht warum amazon hier
ein paket zu schicken aber es ist ja
auch immer mit kreis so geschickt hat
ist ein ballerspiel ab 18 für pc ich mag
dich das nächste paket hier ist von der
lieben raute
die hat mir das zugeschickt das heißt
weil der rauch da will ich jetzt auch
mal sagen dass ich das gar nicht warum
ich hier so auf trab mechanismus sein
sonst auf 10.000 mal mit dieser film ein
bild dieses paket kommt von einem jungen
namens raluca oder ein mädchen ich weiß
jetzt den namen bin ich noch nie gehört
und sie mag hat mir auch einen sticker
freigelegt wir sehen also keine sticker
sondern ein ausbluten zwei alte jetzt
hier kannst du dir bitte sich nehmen und
zurückschicken freunde würde ich gern
machen allerdings bekomme ich sowas dann
immer und das soll so eine einmalige
aktion bleiben immer wenn ich neues
merchandise am start aber sowie zu
verstärkter sache auf jeden fall an sich
raduga für die schlümpfe und für ein
selbst gemachtes radiergummi und für den
schleim
ich habe gestern tatsächlich ein video
von schleim hochgeladen dadurch ein gut
gebrauchen können aber ich habe heute
das paket bekommen aber trotzdem danke
dir
und da fehlten zehnten habe schleim aber
danke dir kannst du das in einem video
auspacken fragt die maya hier ja klar
maya als also hier haben wir irgendwie
ist da drin glaube ich dann hier noch
einen brief und noch ein brief dann
haben wir noch im stundenplan von dass
ich die ganze zeit lukas da also cool
dass du den ganzen weile videos dann hat
mich allerdings noch ein paar mehr dinge
drin und zwar wurde mir wie du
zugeschickt
vom baby liebe die und da hat die maya
mir auch noch einen baby teams mini
kinder kids menü babybrei finden dessen
heute spaghetti mit bio putin
das hört sich eigentlich geil an aber es
ist halt sehr man da hat sie mir noch
irgend so einen komischen wurm
reingelegt der 40 wissen an die schleim
ich weiß nicht finden das war's aber
glaube ich hier auch in dem paket von
der meyer also vielmehr ist jetzt nicht
drin
jedoch so relativ viel vom so untersteht
ist relativ viel von sonnencremes also
das was man von solchen film material
benutzt aber auf jeden fall danke ich
landpaket das blue werde ich nicht
benutzten nächste paket ist hiervon der
mdh die wir immer auch danke für deinen
pakete ich versuch's mal aufrecht
ich hasse rakete einmal kurzfilm dass
man hier mal da ist darum packst du da
zerschnitten ist
konfetti noch rein kommen sofort zurück
selbst die lehrer dass ein video zu
machen
sie soll ich das ding jetzt wieder
auspacken staubige und ich habe jetzt
die alles irgendwie ein bisschen
aufgeräumt
ja ja cool m-klasse direkt wieder sei
sie vorne hat die ma allerdings zum
glück so einen kleinen mechanismus
aufgemacht und da sehen die erst mal
hier eine halb ak gegen die sie dort
sogar mit wolle gemacht hat haben wir
hier noch mehr konfetti klassik ist ein
brief drin oder irgendwie sowas aber ich
weiß dass auch zu privates dann haben
wir eine art diesen teil das sind so
gummibärchen pizza die sind die
schmecken tag um welchen pizza dafür
stehe ich mit meinem namen haben wir
irgendeinen anderen krieg sie haben ja
auch noch irgendwie mentors haben wir
hier haben wir auch noch ein paar
süßigkeiten da ist auch schleim drin der
mir geschenkt wurde also freunde du
kannst du dir gerade mal danke danke
danke für dein paket
ich musste allerdings das paket erst mal
komplett absaugen damit ich das
irgendwie weiter verwerten kann
wenn ihr das wollt dann macht bitte
nicht mit konfetti das
das scheint nicht mal den kanal genannt
wenn ich nicht videos über minecraft
gemacht hätte sondern war nicht so dünne
menschen konfetti anstatt kongress so
wenig schlaf da sondern fertig konfetti
ihr witz ich danke gott mit uns im
vorletzten paket meine damen und herren
das hat mich an ihm zugeschickt hier
vorne
das ist 3d supply tv-film drauf deswegen
denke ich mal dass es vielleicht vom 3ds
bleiben was sein könnte
dies ist nix von 3d supply die karten
dem buch geschenkt so fällt unseren fans
brutal das ist immer mega geil dass
maximal uns mit anderen büchern finden
wir die anderen bücher also sind auf
jeden fall einige mit am start nur durch
lesen muss alter die gaben an ihre erste
banane meine erste banane zonen gaby
dies die sitze sind diese auf 70 oder
die zeitung ist vom 23
januar 2018 hat zwar eine zeitung vom 23
januar 2011 presse
ich will mal den karton neue schuhe und
komik hallo mein name ist miley
irgendwoher kenne ich dich vielleicht
von diesen nein jetzt weiß ich ich kann
sie auch sagen zehn langen politischen
findet weiß ich erwarte und vom lukasz
ob luca shop.de
wie komme ich werde ich auf jeden fall
darauf an die wand oben kleben dann
haben wir hier vorne noch ein
gebasteltes mai die drin daran diesen
diesem lionel messi da reingekommen dann
wurden wir jedoch mikrowellen popcorn
geschenk das ist sogar wirklich ganz
geil ist wenn wir gleich mal essen dann
haben wir hier noch so ein paar
problemchen dann haben wir noch einen
schlüsselanhänger center schocks danke
auf jeden fall auch an dich liebe lena
für das paket was du mir aus österreich
geschickt hast danke dafür und jetzt
haben wir hier vorne halten noch
unmengen wirklich an briefen die ich
jetzt alle vorlesen könnte und aufmachen
könnte allerdings wird das das komplette
video springen ich weiß jetzt da
vielleicht auch private sachen drin
stehen und so weiter und so fort
deswegen würde ich sagen an der stelle
freunde da ist auch das setzt confed
jetzt runter gefallen ich würde das
video dieser stelle hier zu beenden
das hier ist der tisch wird dem ich das
ganze hier gemacht habe das ist der
stoff sollte ich das auch gesagt dass da
das war doch das war ein super klasse
videofilm sei kein wort